three two one
that was early that was that was early
three two one clap oh here we go
three two one
great
what the [ __ ]
jesus
why don't you he should do the
clap i'll judge you doing the clap it's
a lot of pressure to do the clap right
uh let me explain to people in case we
ever use this
that you need to do a sync clap if one
of us isn't here
sona and i are in studio uh matt gourley
uh is uh in pasadena i won't give the
exact street
because i think he'd be attacked
immediately you don't know it
and i have no idea what it is
i've been there once but he made me wear
a blindfold because he didn't want me to
know where he lives uh but anyway yeah
but anyway we have to do a sync clap to
make sure that we are all in audio sync
eduardo counted you down for the clap
and your clap was way off he did three
two one and you did it like that and so
you did it in three and a half instead
of on what
would have been four yeah and so i was
just making fun of your clap and then
you did another clap which wasn't great
i think your tempo it's a lot of
pressure cause you're they're counting
down and it's a lot of pressure because
you're like a lot of pressure you're
couldn't notice i don't know why anytime
there's a countdown involved in anything
it's it's nerve-wracking there's never
been less pressure we're in a podcast
studio all you have to do is clap if you
don't get it perfectly right we do it
again
there is pressure though because you're
going to ride her ass super hard if she
thank you yeah because yeah and then
you're here right next right next to me
so matt you zoomed in just so you could
take sona's side that's what you did
yeah i gotta run i me i came when
i can't believe he zooms in he's like
the cavalry comes in yeah and it doesn't
save me just immediately puts a bullet
through my head to be safe
you can see you're the oppressor here
let me help you eduardo give me the
countdown and i'll give you the correct
go here we go three two one
that's right on time that is called good
that is called a point though he's also
he's really trying right now no i'm not
i've never clapped that like
confidently you've never clapped that i
have loudly before it's called having a
sense of time and tempo
you don't have that
um you are born without it i don't know
what happened to you uh as a child and
i'm sorry
but we shouldn't rely on sona anymore
for the clap sync what do you think matt
i think you're wrong i believe in sona i
think we can do this sona eduardo clap
her in again and sony i don't want to do
it again
you are the worst worst worst to be next
to right now i hate this sometimes the
worst is also the best i'm actually my
hands are never all right never by
definition it's never the best
i'm so nervous i believe here we go
three two one
that was
it felt a little early felt eduardo what
do you think be honest
it was really good
edward edwardo
do it at the same time without looking
at each other and see who's more on okay
here we go all right countess in three
two one
oh
you're both pretty insane i was
perfectly in sync and then you saw me
and didn't ah no no i didn't mean to say
shut up i don't like it when people say
i do i'll say shut up oh you second most
all you say to me is
you you is that what you say to your
kids when they're being too
harsh
yeah slowly gently i think that you
come once
ugh you were waiting for me to mess up
the clap you were looking at me you
couldn't wait and then when i went too
fast you like dove in and i think that
you're creating a very hostile work
environment and i don't like it and i
want to go cry in the bathroom hey sona
maybe you can cancel him for his clap
pressure and this could be like a
landmark case
yeah this is what takes me down is that
i publicly shamed you
for being uh off tempo with your clap
can i ask you like a serious question
yeah were you ready to scrutinize my
clap nope not at all i just heard it and
it didn't sound right now
eduardo picked up on it too i could see
in his eyes
um
eduardo has very expressive eyes and
they weld up with disappointments
you didn't you immediately as soon as i
clapped now you jumped in and criticized
me for it and i don't i don't like sona
sona i think you're an incredible person
listen that's the worst no listen
i think you're an incredible person but
you do have
some flaws and one of them is terrible
clap tempo okay awful
maybe the worst i've ever seen i'm never
doing that again i just want everybody
here to know i'm never doing the
collapsing okay and that's the end of
this segment in three
two one
perfect
i taught you well you didn't teach me
anything peace out